[Music]
a
n
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them to be on the ballot or not to be on
the ballot that is the
question is it the question we want
answered I don't know I don't think
so the secretary of state of Maine seems
to be terrified to make that
decision so much so she's like I need
the Supreme Court to weigh in on this
one uh months ago go when this stuff
started to arise I said out loud as I
normally do I usually don't talk under
my breath I said out loud that there
would not be a secretary of state that
would want to use unilateral power to
take Trump off the
ballot there has been one that has been
forced to be asked the question because
of how Maine's laws work she was forced
to uh answer the question this petition
and she's kind of punting to let the
Supreme Court ask because she doesn't
want to
be murdered by Maga terrorist well what
do you want from me last night I was
invited on a Twitter space with Mario
Neal's Twitter spaces um which there's a
lot of right-wingers that appear in
those spaces um there's some people who
are liberals that appear in those
spaces I usually cause trouble when I go
in there I haven't been in there in a
while um I did listen last night uh to
part of the space I'm going to play
parts of it for you today and I only
think it's relevant because of what a
trump bootlicking Maga supporting
terrorist in Colorado excuse me chairman
did I say terrorist oh my
God I mean chairman of the GOP I showed
you a clip of him last week on Laura
loomer's Podcast or whatever the hell
that thing is where he wouldn't say go
[__] yourself do you remember that and
she's like no say it he's like oh I
don't want the underage children who
watch your show to say me to hear me say
the f word [__]
yourself so he ended up actually saying
it and then that's how he introduced
himself last night which I'm probably
not gonna play that part because who
gives a [__] about that that he says the
FW I'm gonna I'm gonna quote Evon
muskier that's literally how he says
it that's how you know he's such a
[__] idiot
I think his name's Dave Dave Williams
something like that he's the
Colorado GOP
chairman he said on the on the Twitter
space to donate to Trump he said those
[__] words he didn't say donate to
other candidates he said donate to Trump
definitely donate to Trump is what he
said I I'm I'm not trying to [__] put
words in his mouth that's what he said
and I'm gonna play parts of the
questioning um from other panelists that
were asking him questions some of it's
very funny it is very funny in his
response but some of it gives you a
clear-cut idea that what I have been
saying is absolutely [__]
true and it is the abnor abnormal
reality that we live in that we need we
need to wrap our heads around because I
believe that some of the disagreement
that is
happening with me and these 14th
amends is that they believe we live in a
certain type of normal reality and we do
not we do not not only is Trump not
going to act normal and be normal nor is
the Republican Party
folks they're [__]
Nazis okay Nazis did not act normal that
was not a normal thing to want to
[__] exterminate an entire group of
people in 1930s and the 40s it was
Jewish people in Germany and anyone who
dissented against their extermination of
Jewish people that's not normal okay not
[__] normal not normal stuff I
mean maybe if you live you know in a
world where fascism is cool but it's
not these people are not normal and
you're going to see that this Colorado
uh GOP chairman is not normal these are
not normal
circumstances these people are not going
to follow the rule of law they're not
going to respect the courts I mean even
in places like Alabama where Alabama's
like no you can't you can't draw
districts like that and they're like
hide and watch [__] we don't give a
[__] what you
say I I can even I can even go way back
way back remember when the Supreme Court
ruled that St Zack marriage was legal
and that counties had to start giving um
licenses and a lot of counties like [__]
you and I forget her name you remember
this lady she refused to give a marriage
license she was a she was an elected
County Clerk and she refused to give a
[__] marriage license it was
somewhere in I don't know know Kentucky
or Tennessee or some
[__] Mike Huckabee Mike Huckabee went
there yeah Mike hakabe went to the
county courthouse and supported her and
then she served a little bit of jail
time she was kicked out of office
right
they Trump one of the criminal trials
that he's going to go on is because he
doesn't respect the rule of
law he had documents he had a chance to
give them back and not be charged with
obstruction they don't give a [__] they
don't
care they're not
normal they're not living in the same
reality that you're living in okay and
they don't give a
[__] about the reality that you actually
live in with facts and the truth and you
know Tethered to an actual reality that
exist exist they don't give a [__] about
that it's a
cult the Republican party is [__]
dead that's why I speak out against you
know Adam kininger and Liz Cheney and
Chris Christie when when they when
they're doing the thing that they should
be doing but it's for the wrong reason
they're not in it to save democracy they
say that but their goal like Paul Ryan
the same is to revive the Republican
party it's dead and you do not come back
from dictator like you don't you don't
your party doesn't you know do the
dictator
snowball it snowed this morning here I'm
doing the snow references but you don't
you don't
revive a a Republican party that does
the dictator snowball because this is
going to a snowball way out of control
um as far as the Republican party is
concerned because that's the other
[__]
thing it really confuses me about this
14th Amendment uh [__] because I I get
super excited about mate teers I mean I
love swimming in MERS and they are
creating Seas oce of
MERS over the possibility of Donald
Trump not appearing on Republican
primary
ballots just see I mean even radama
dingdong V is out there saying I'm not
GNA be on any ballot that Donald Trump
isn't on boo [__] who which really if
you think about it if you re if the
radama dingdong was really in the race
to beat Donald Trump which he supposed
to be he's in a primary that's his goal
is to beat Donald Trump and be the
nominee you would think that he would
want to be for sure on a ballot that his
opponent is
not it only makes it glaringly obvious
that V rad damama dingdong has always
been a plant in the trump in the Trump
campaign so there's that
too but I want you to remember this as
we talk about this today and I want you
to remember this very clearly and the
reason why is because when I show you
the questioning um and I I wish I wish I
would have uh maybe I'll see if she'll
come on the show next week to talk about
this but she because she asked in Tara
in the Twitter space uh another panelist
ask this Colorado
GOP uh
chairman about the general election
ballot and then uh Sarah someone else
who followed up with the question on the
general election ballot you're going to
hear that back and forth um with that
it's really
important and the reason why it's
important is because they're going to
decide they don't give a [__] what the
law decides they're going to nominate
their dictator their King their cult
leader their mango musolini Jesus
grantpa
Hitler as the Republican
nominee that's they're going to do
it it doesn't matter what the courts
want now I I believe my belief is is
that uh sometime next week Wednesday
Thursday or Friday we will have a
decision from the Supreme Court which
will absolutely take the wind out of all
these cases sales um saying no you can't
you can't take Trump off a Republican
primary ballot you can't do that um
which is going to trigger then a a a a
battle in the courts for the general
election ballot but I'm really clear
when that can and can't start because he
would have to be the clear-cut winner
and start applying for this general
election ballots to be printed so each
State's going to have different printing
dates uh and different deadlines so
we'll see court cases work their way
through the courts in those States for
the general election ballots um which is
really the that's the ballot that's
going to prevent him to becoming
president not the primary ballots and
all these court cases that everyone is
yay he's off the ballot yay he's not
going to be president none of them none
of them are the general election ballots
none of them none of them they're only
the Republican party's primary
ballots and the Republican party in each
state gets to
determine how they send their delegates
to the convention right now each party
does this Democrats do it Republicans do
it those are the two major part parties
and then you have Libertarians you have
the green party there's other parties in
other states like those that are you
know third parties or outliers that have
a way of selecting delegates at their
National Convention because these are
National
tickets okay these are National tickets
these are not local tickets these are
not State Senate these are not uh uh
United States Representatives you not
governor race this is the presidential
election it's much different than the
those other elections much different
it's one reason why I believe that the
lower court in Colorado ruled that Trump
was or excuse me Trump as the president
but the president of the United States
is not an officer of the government he
is the executive so you want to argue
that people can argue that but I don't
think that's going to be the point
that's going to be argued in the Supreme
Court but I think that's why they did
that is because it is different it's
much different
and then if you really understand the
delegate process uh for the presidential
ticket in the parties uh and how the
states because each state is different
on how they give their delegates some
are the same but they're all they all
have their way of giving the delegates
uh for instance in Missouri the
Republican party has a primary but it
doesn't mean to [__] shine Ola it
doesn't mean [__] they have a huge
primary we spend Missouri taxpayer
dollars to have a Missouri primary
Missouri and it doesn't fck fing matter
it doesn't decide anything
nothing I'm serious decides nothing they
go to the convention which is normally
held in you know somewhere by St Louis
or Kansas City or Springfield Missouri
because the those are the bigger
Metropolitan metropolitan areas um in
Missouri I I do that because Springfield
is not I mean it's like the third
largest city in Missouri but it it's not
that big it's just not that [__] big
I've been there a lot it's not that
big any who I digress from that but they
go to the State
Convention and at the State
Convention those people who represent
the delegates in the
counties select the delegates that are
going to go to the National Convention
to give their votes to the
nominee at the Republican National
Convention that's how Missouri does
it and they decide that they're going to
do that way cuz it's their party you see
it's their party now the problem that
Republicans have in this instance or
maybe it's not their problem maybe it's
our problem right people who believe in
democracy the problem that arises in
this situation where they're trying to
keep him off a primary ballot is then it
doesn't matter if he's on a primary
ballot or not and you're going to see
this Colorado GOP chairman uh say this
and folks I want I want you to know this
and this is why I am so
[__] exhausted about even talking
about this [__] issue because it's so
[__] dumb it's dumb it's dumb that
they're that people are trying to do
this it's dumb that that they just won't
[__] let the voters decide and and I
get it people like but the Constitution
the Constitution the Constitution it's
clearcut even people I know and respect
and Love by the way are saying that the
14th third the third section is clear
cut and dry and it's not it's not clear
cut and dry it is not that is [__]
if it was clearcut and dry we wouldn't
have these cases going to the Supreme
Court we wouldn't if we lived in normal
times and it was so
clearcut we wouldn't be asking these
questions so it's not clear cut and dry
this is not normal
stuff I think it's
dumb that we're doing this because I
believe that the narrative is the thing
that's going to win us the election not
the courts not Jack Smith these things
are not going to win us the election in
2024 and by us I mean democracy I don't
give a [__] that Joe Biden's going to be
the
nominee I just want democracy to [__]
win not the
fash when I show you this this uh clip
of the Colorado uh uh Republican GOP
terrorist I mean chairman excuse me I
keep misspoke what do you want me to
do um when you hear him speaking you
hear him say what he's
saying and you and
you you got to read between the fash um
read between the lies as I've said
before once you see it then you'll
know all this [__] that we're doing that
we're getting excited about oh all the
Liberals are on social media yeah woohoo
it ain't going to make a
difference it ain't gonna make a
difference because number one Supreme
Court's going to rule in Trump's favor
that is going to be a thing and number
two even if they don't the GOP is not
going to give a [__] they're not going
to give a [__] cuz these are primary
ballots you're not listening they're
primary ballots
these are primary ballots the primary
ballots primary ballots primary ballots
don't get confused these are not general
election ballots and they won't decide
the general election ballots until the
summer at the
convention there is going to be an
apparent nominee but not an actual
nominee I just I can't stress enough how
much you should use the thinky space
that you have to determine what the
narrative should be because the
narrative is going to win us the
election it always does we were talking
about it this morning in the producers
corner you guys know that I do a a
special hour with the patreon members if
you're $20 patreon member um then you
you can come into the producers meeting
every Monday and Friday an hour before
the show if you're having trouble doing
that just message me on patreon and I'll
try to get you situated
or or at least get you in a position
with someone who knows how to get you
situated it's probably like skip or
Mighty
librarian over there on
Discord because I'm a bonehead when it
comes to that thing they got to show me
things and they got to show me around
how how that stuff works anyways anyways
uh but if you want to come join that
producers Corner this morning we were
talking about the border and how people
think um and I'm not going to get into
the details of who we were talking about
that' be a long story come to the
producers Corner we'll probably talking
about it next
week anywh who um we were talking about
how people think the border the border
border that's going to be a big [__]
thing everyone's going to make their
decision they're going to vote based on
the border that's all a bunch of
[__] that's all a bunch of
[__] it's 100%
[__] they're not going to make
you're you're not going to make a
decision for the vice president of
United States based on the
border you're not they're not it's not a
thing because that's not going to be the
narrative that's not going to be the
loudest narrative the loudest narrative
is going to be hey they want to take
your [__] rights away like they did
with roie Wade and he wants to be a
dictator the same guy who took your
rights away because he's bragging about
taking roie Wade killing roie Wade he
wants to kill your rights to by being a
dictator it's going to be the [__]
narrative that's that's the driving
narrative that's it and you can rely on
that driving narrative trust me trust me
I mean you can doubt me on it doubt me
if you want but trust me on
this that will be the driving
narrative because he will be the nominee
I'm going to show you the evidence of
why he's going to be the
nominee today from the Colorado GOP
terrorist excuse me chairman chairman
chairman keep getting that wrong
oh boy so yesterday we talked about um
um where I broadcast from and I want to
keep this going because I think this is
great because we do this show every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Facebook twitch and now
Instagram I'm thinking about
rebroadcasting back on Twitter and the
only reason why stay with me on this the
only reason why is because now I can see
the Twitter
comments I'm considering it I'm
considering it but either way we
broadcast from the antifa
headquarters in Kami Falls Missouri so
we're here I'm here at the antifa
corporate headquarters for the daily
antifa meeting that's what this is the
Tony Michaels podcast is your daily
2hour 2our antifa meeting uh every
single weekday here on the interwebs uh
and we broadcast from the antifa of
corporate headquarters in commi Falls
Missouri whatever I don't know I think
that I think I think people like that
and you know what yesterday someone said
something we talked about um antifa
membership card I think I'm going to put
that in the merch
store I think we're going to make one
we're going to make an and you're going
to have to pay your membership fee
you're going to have to buy the the the
sticker I'm probably going to make it a
sticker so that way you can like buy the
sticker and go slap it on your your like
your [__] maanga uncle's car or some
[__] on his car window or like on their
their [__] mirror in their bathroom
you know what I mean just put it up
there official antifa membership
card I I don't know I think I think that
would be [__] great uh if we had one
of those in the merch store um and I I I
don't think it would ever die either it
would be a great joke to continue and
and I'll put the commi Falls address on
there so everyone knows um where to meet
uh if you want to physically meet
um oh boy Everyone likes the idea they
like the idea um make it a magnet for
cars yeah we could do a magnet maybe a
sticker uh we can make metal signs we
could do all kinds of stuff we can do
all kinds of stuff um with the uh with
the antifa official membership card um
so maybe maybe I'll do that over the
over the weekend and over the New Year
holidays which brings me to a piece of
business okay we do not have bonehead of
the week today I know it's Friday but
Gabe Sanchez is traveling but here's the
thing we wanted to do bonehead of the
year and he said it makes more sense to
do it next week and it really does if
you think about it okay so bear with me
on this it's December 29th to day right
and we still got a lot of the day left
and we still have the 30th the 30 the in
the 31st year to get through so and we
know these boneheads come in at the last
[__] minute I mean like we had the
Lauren bobert news yesterday where she's
going to go um uh suck the juice out of
Colorado's forth and abandon the her
constituents in Colorado's thirdd
because she can't win um so we got that
so she could possibly be a candidate who
knows what Marjorie Taylor green is
going to say in the next two days who
[__] knows who knows what Donald
Trump could actually [__] post on
fraud social I mean Jesus Christ who
knows what could happen so here's what
we're going to do that's why there was
not a bonehead of the week poll this
week there will be one next week and the
one next week will be for Bon head of
the year that's right we will do
bonehead of the year next week so you
can decide who the bone end of the year
was in 2023 and you'll get to consider
all the way up till the very moment when
that ball drops at midnight you will be
able to put everything into that uh into
that
consideration um yeah we're going to do
bonehead of the year we're going to do
bonehead of the Year V Robinson asked so
we're going to do bonee of the year next
year and I I wanted to have bon of the
week today but Gabe's traveling um so
and it's a short week so we we just we
weren't able to do bonehead of the week
today but we will do bonehead of the
week or bonehead of the year next year
um everyone's saying um some are
postulating Ken Paxton Donald Trump I'm
telling you there I mean someone could
slide in right there at the end you know
what I mean to be bonehead of the year
we've got we've got a lot of hours left
of the Republican Party acting like
[__] boneheads and that brings me to
my next piece of news uh next week
bonehead of the year we are not going to
have a show on Monday or Tuesday for the
holiday I'm going to probably be
really [__] hung over I don't know
I'm thinking about staying um I'm
thinking about staying home because our
anniversary is this weekend too and it's
18 I've been married for 18 years that's
right this guy this this guy that looks
like this has been married for 18 years
and really um for forunate enough for me
my wife has been able to keep putting up
with me for a that's really the story
here that's the story here and again I
don't make this show about me a lot but
that's the story here is that don't
congratulate me congratulate well you
probably should congratulate me that my
wife has been able to put up with me for
years so I appreciate all the
congratulations so um this weekend is
going to be a full weekend uh for me
um and you know 18 years is I think
about that I say it out loud I'm like 18
Jesus 18 years holy [__] so I appreciate
um all your congratulations and another
piece of business I have is Felicia
McCrae has a birthday in the chat and to
everyone who has a birthday in the chat
for the next several days because we're
not going to be on the air happy
birthday to you so happy birthday to
Felicia happy birthday to you you happy
everyone in the chat especially Felicia
McCrae so thank you thank you thank you
for being here today on the Tony
Michaels podcast December 29th the last
show of the year in
2024 uh broadcasting live from antifa
corporate headquarters in commi Falls
Missouri as we do our daily antifa
meeting here for two full hours Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on Facebook YouTube twitch and
now Instagram make sure to hit the
Subscribe button make sure to follow us
everywhere go to the Tony michaels.com
to find all the links how to support
this show because you the audience are
what keeps this microphone powered
against fascism don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hugs spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say m pepperoni hug spot it's like
family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show the final show
of the
Year 2023 we will start 2024 very soon
we'll start it next Wednesday here uh at
the antifa corporate headquarters in
commi Falls Missouri for your daily dose
of antifa
meeting I like the Ring of that you know
what I mean I like
that I like that so A year in review
I've been listening to a lot of year in
reviews and I you know I just want to
say that 2023 has been uh a crazy year
it really has it's been a [__] wild
ride and we're not done yet with this
stupid [__] 14th Amendment [__] that
people keep trying to push yes it's
stupid [__] it's dumb I'm going to show
you a clip here in a little bit of the
Colorado GOP terrorist excuse me
chairman Jesus Christ I keep misspeaking
chairman not terrorist good
Lord uh but we're gonna we're going to
listen to a little bit of uh a back and
forth that happened on the Twitter space
last night that I was invited to I
didn't go talk but I was listening and I
think it's going to give you a little
insight of what I'm talking about and
why what I'm saying is about narrative
and it's about the politics of it that's
what I speak to all the time people are
like Tony you're not a [__] lawyer
and I'm like yeah I know I'm not a
[__] lawyer I know that I I I didn't
go to law school I didn't pass the bar I
know I'm not a lawyer well it ain't that
hard to be a lawyer I probably could be
one but I not one I not a lawyer I get
it but I'm a political commentator so
guess what I get to do I get to
commentate on the [__] politics of it
and I'm telling you that the politics of
this 14th Amendment stuff is not good
for
Democrats it's not it's not it's it's
not it's not and I know you don't see it
now because what you want is something
that is probably not going to be given
to you where Trump isn't the
nominee like that's the goal right to
take him off a [__]
ballot right it's the goal to not let
him be the
Nomine
that's the
goal but they're not going to let you do
that that's what you don't understand
what I keep trying to yell and scream
and some of you really get it and that's
why you come here is because this is
Refuge from the [__]
stupidity and the the misinformation and
the [__] that the media and people
who pretend to be the media want to give
you CU I'm I'm I'm not the mainstream
media this is actual liberal media
that's what this
is this is liberal commentary not
leftwing not
radical this is liberal
commentary all the other [__] people
are talking about how they oh they're
cheering that he's off the ballot yay
all my friends and I I'm the outcast but
it's because I see clearly what is going
to
happen maybe it's because I'm from
the culture to some degree that Maga
comes from that it's bred from maybe
that's the reason why I I understand it
a little bit I I don't know what it is
exactly but I I just see it clearly and
it may be because I don't
really um get too um attached to this
idea that it has to happen a certain way
and it has to you know like who gives a
it's going to happen the way it's going
to happen stop trying to make it
something different than it
is and yes this 14th Amendment stuff is
very bad for Democrats narrative it's
really bad and the reason why it's
really bad because it's really good for
their narrative it's really good for
their narrative it really is oh it's a
gift it's a gift to them and that's
really the commentating that I do every
day um and and I want everyone to
understand that is that I'm not coming
from this from a legal angle
ever I mean I'll give you what the what
happens in the court and give you the
facts and tell you the truth about the
law and how it works and all that stuff
like I tell you the 14th Amendment
section three is not clear and the
reason why it's not clear is because
we're asking these questions if it was
clear then we wouldn't have to do this
we wouldn't be doing this if it was so
clear just the [__] cold hard truth
you may not like it that way but that's
what it is I want to clear up something
here shz okay Tony what gives you the
right to call us terrorists I didn't
call you a terrorist we are patriots he
says I said the word terrorist for GOP
and you got offended so I'm talking to
you I'm talking to you if you get
offended that I say the word terrorist
and you think I'm talking about you I am
talking about you Chez you [__]
Russian bot Putin's puppet over here
being paid by Putin to be offended that
I called someone else a terrorist and he
says you can't call us terrorist dude
you're a terrorist that's what it makes
me
think
whoosh
whoosh the
stupidity [__] stupidity is
ridiculous I didn't call you a terrorist
dude you assumed I called you a
terrorist which probably makes you that
all right so uh again in this in this U
Twitter space where the Colorado GOP
Terrace excuse me Chaz
chairman I didn't mean to offend you you
[__] snowflake oh my God you're so
offended by
words do you notice that they're the
ones offended by words you ever notice
that you ever notice
that oh man goddamn
woo mud mud points out a good point here
on YouTube
that's what gives us the right oh oh
hang on that's what gives us the right I
the wrong one I'm sorry Paul says me
think th do protest too
much so thanks for your guys's comments
there Tony Pierce says here Tony you
know you really want RFK to
win all right so before I I like this
comment I like this this um and I'll
I'll play ball with you here
Tony um I actually believe that RFK is
good in the fight for uh democracy in
that it's it's a it's a plus minus game
on RFK Jr meaning H he's going to take
more votes away from Trump than he takes
away from Biden so it's kind of a plus
minus thing if that makes sense if that
makes sense at all so um I I don't see
him as a threat
I I mean he's a threat to you
know he's a threat
to to Trump possibly so oh mud Winks I
think you're winking at me wink there
you
go oh someone says here Texas Paul just
went over this issue with the 14th you
do not have to indict or convict it for
to apply a disqualification is not a
criminal punishment listen if that was
so clear-cut they would not be asking
this question this question I hate to
tell you this but Paul is going to be
wrong on this issue he's going to be
wrong if this was so clear-cut and dry
it would be done listen to me clearly
Coy Griffin who is a county commissioner
in New Mexico an elected official was
found guilty for his role during January
6th okay they used the 14th Amendment
section three to remove him from that
County Commission you got me they did
not do that until he was convicted got
it you got it the reason why this
question exist is because it has never
been done the way that you and Paul are
saying it's been done that's the [__]
rub here that's what I'm trying to tell
you and this does not apply to a general
election ballot it only applies to each
state who files a case for the primary
ballot okay got it know
it and again I would have Paul on and
challenge him on this issue if is not
clear cut and
dry it is
not it is
not so again I wish descent and I
welcome descent even from Paul I welcome
descent you've watched Paul and me have
disagreements on this
show but just because someone says
something even me just because someone
says something does not mean that you
should not stop using your thinking
space it is important it is very [__]
important and when someone tells you
that this is clearcut and dry and then
it's a slam dunk they're Mis they're
misinforming you it's what they're doing
that's what they're doing I hate to tell
you that but that's what is happening
and it's because it's popular on Twitter
too right like oh man the popular
opinion on Twitter is to be for Trump
being off ballots that's the PO their
opinion it's a shitty narrative it's a
really shitty narrative it's so [__]
terrible because everyone is
underestimating how much Americans are
not paying
attention way highly underestimating we
pay attention my audience pays attention
Texas Paul's audience pays attention
midus touch's audience pays
attention they pay attention but you're
underestimating how much Americans don't
pay
attention but to tiny little
nuggets that's the point of the [__]
narrative okay that's the point of it
the right-wing knows this all too well
and they use it to their advantage to
beat us every [__]
time and I just wish people would wrap
their [__] minds around that what do
you think do you think half these people
believe the garbage that they stand at
Trump Nazi rallies saying in the
microphones all this [__] just
nonsense just [__] they're like oh
Trump invented the vaccine but the
vaccine
bad do you think that their cognitive
dissonance do you think that that is
just a just a [__]
fluke no it's not a [__] fluke it's a
goddamn
feature and until you come to grips with
that truth with that truth our narrative
is GNA can is going to keep kicking Us
in the ass because they're doing a
better job at it and folks they've been
pounding this election interference drum
for almost two goddamn years now two
[__] years ever since Jack Smith was
was made the special counsel and they
were going to bring charges against
Trump in New York and this documents
case and the January 6th case they've
been pounding pounding this message of
election
interference pounding it pounding the
drum
and even though even though it's not
really Democrats that are doing this
because it's Republican primary ballots
it's Republicans in Colorado that
brought this
case it doesn't matter they don't care
about the truth they don't give a [__]
about it they don't give a
[__] they only care about their power
that's it that's it
period and I'm going to show you in this
clip
until you fully understand that you're
going to you're not going to understand
that this narrative the 14th Amendment
stuff is going to rip Democrats to
shreds in some places folks we want to
win as many house races as we can we
want to win as many United States Senate
seats as we can we will beat Trump he
will be easy to beat but we need to do
more than just beat trump our democracy
relies on [__] making Maga and
fascism crawl back underneath its
[__] rocket and our future in this
democracy is way more [__] important
than that [__] fat slob Grandpa
Hitler okay it's way more [__]
important than his
dumbass he is just a [__] Speck in
the history of our
democracy and a smelly one a smelly
Speck of [__] he's almost like the
dingleberry you know what I mean he's
the dingleberry of our history
stink but it's just a small part there's
so much more future ahead for our
democracy there's so much more that we
can and will
do and we can't keep our eye off that
prize we cannot and we cannot afford to
let the right out narrative
us we
can't
I'm telling you folks telling you right
now there are [__] out there
that right now as we speak who know
nothing about these ballots know nothing
about this news not a goddamn thing
about it they're concerned about what
[__] alcohol they're going to be
drinking over the weekend for New Year's
and who they're going to be kissing and
[__]
okay when the ball drops that's what
they're focused on they don't give a
[__] about this they don't
care I know it feels like they should
but they don't it's the
reality those people out there right now
they would vote for Trump or
Biden because they really truly believe
in their heart of hearts that it doesn't
matter which one is the president they
take for granted their life and their
lifestyle and everything around them
that it just happens and it'll just be
there now we all know that that's not
the full truth we all know that we know
that here sitting here right
now but they don't that's their
cognitive dissonance I mean maa's
cognitive dissonance is [__] way out
loud and it's obvious these other folks
that will go either way they will vote
either [__]
way they
matter because there's people in
Pennsylvania that will do that there's
people in in Ohio that will do that
there's people in Michigan there's
people in Georgia there's people in
Arizona and we cannot lose the narrative
we are winning we have been winning with
this [__]
narrative and if we give them if we give
them the
narrative we don't deserve to
win
so let's deserve to
win that's what I'm calling
for because this narrative that you can
just wipe someone off the ballot and
that people are going to be like wait
what what I want to vote against that
[__] or what how are you going
to decide how are you going to decide
who I can and cannot vote for what the
[__] does that mean so I don't actually
get a vote that's going to be the
[__] narrative that they're going to
spin and guess what it's going to take
hold in
places it's going to take
hold people are going to
say wait I thought they were taking him
off the ballot now he's on the ballot so
Trump's the truth and Democrats are
liars that's another narrative uh Randy
here says it's in the Constitution they
don't give a [__] Randy the people that
I'm talking about that are going to go
vote that would vote either way that
don't care which one's president they
don't think it
matters they don't they don't give a
[__] about the Constitution that the
right to vote is afforded to them to a
document that they don't give a [__]
about that's the point I'm trying to
make to you that's the
point and we we people who care about
the Constitution who care about the vote
who care about the democracy and know
that what's at stake we can't lose that
reality
we can't go so far off the [__] deep
end that we have lost our tether to what
is
real and what is real is if we lose the
narrative he can
win and he's going to be their [__]
nominee I don't give a [__] what ballot
you take him off of which you're not
going to I don't give a [__] they're
going to make him nominee and they're
going to do it through athor
authoritarianism they're they're anth
itarian party that is who they are that
is what they are that is what they're
going to continue to be they are not
going to they cannot run from
that that's what is going to happen and
I know these are hard truths and this is
hard stuff to to kind of wrap around
because what you want is for him to go
away right that's ultimately what the
majority of people in this country want
rather they're going to vote against him
or vote for him or don't give a [__]
they ultimately want that son of a [__]
to just go away shut the [__] up and go
we've had enough of you we've had enough
of
you and we can use that narrative we can
pack that in we can pack that into our
narrative right to present it to the
American people and go hey you got a
decision to
make you're going to vote someone you
really [__] hate for and can't stand
and he wants to be a dictator or you
going to vote for the guy who's safe oh
vote for the guy who's
safe don't you
see don't you
see I I and and and I'm telling you um
six weeks from now four weeks from now
five weeks from now maybe a week from
now the media is really catching on
quicker because I think we have several
producers from MSNBC that watch this
show CU this morning I caught a Little
Bit Of The Morning Show on
MSNBC uh to see what they were talking
about mainly they were talking about the
the year in recap and the New Year and
that sort of thing but they started to
talk about Nikki Haley and I I honestly
you you got you producers that are
listening I got to give you props you
literally are taking what I say on this
show and you are pumping it in to MSNBC
in the morning show almost immediately
now like you're not waiting months like
you're just flat out going straight to
it wh boom I said yesterday Nicki Haley
would never be the president of the
United States never be the nominee no
[__] way in chance in hell and
everyone was say yeah she the she's all
man she the next D she the upand coming
all the Coke brothers are supporting her
and all the big money
don't and then this morning on MSNBC
she's like she's done she's over [__]
her she can't be the
nominee over and over and
over so I want to I want to I want to
congratulate you to finally finding um
where you should be listening to produce
your content over on
MSNBC
yeah yeah all that yakety schacky [__]
yakety
schacky oh boy do you want to see this
clip or not give it to me give it to me
give it to
me okay all right let's go to this clip
now this is uh pretty long this is like
six and a half minutes um and it's not
the full it's not the
full uh interview when he was in the
room cuz he comes in the room he's there
for like 18 minutes 18 20 minutes is
what he's
talking
um Tony you're helping them you're
helping them what do you mean I'm
helping them what do you mean because
I'm I'm saying your narrative The
Narrative around the 14th Amendment
sucks because they're going to use that
narrative no the people doing this 14th
let me
okay Cosmo I hope you're here every
single day and I hope you continue to
come back every single day and I hope
you disagree agree with me at least once
or twice a week that's what I hope
that's what I'm hoping for I want dcent
that democracy doesn't live without
dissent if you don't know that whoosh
that's where authoritarianism is bred is
when there is no descent when they get
rid of them when they execute them when
they [__] exterminate them because
they are you're not you're new will
agree with me where you're gone
[__] I'm not helping them I'm
not helping them I'm commenting on what
is happening
okay I'm commenting on what is happening
and what I see happening that is going
to snowball
into what will happen with narrative I
don't give a [__] about the [__]
legal [__] I mean yeah I do but that's
not my wheelhouse I'm not a lawyer I'm I
don't commentate on the [__] the
[__] legal issues I think it's a
waste of time because the courts are
going to do what they're going to do and
then you can report on what they
did
right and I can postulate on the
political ramifications that the Supreme
Court is going to make on this and I can
postulate on the politics of why the
Supreme Court isn't going to [__]
ruin Colorado's favor they're going to
ruin Trump's favor and once they do that
boom it's done poof like a [__] fart
in the win it's going to go over like a
wet fart in a white thong but they now
have the narrative they now have it they
have captured the
narrative they have captured the
narrative not because of
me not because of me I mean I guess I
wish it was because of me but it's not
because of
me it's because of this [__] that keeps
snowballing with this 14th Amendment
[__] that is that that at its core at
its
core at its core
is the same legal laware if you want to
call it that that Trump was trying to
use in 20120 get to get them to overturn
the election and change ballots and
change and change the decision in the
courts that he lost 62 to nothing or
some [__] he lost 61 or 62 times in
court they have about the same
record a lot of these cases in these
states have been dropped for these
primary ballots that's the other thing I
want you to know is that this has
nothing to do with the Democratic party
it has nothing to do with it because
these are not these are not Democratic
party ballots that these are going to
appear on these are Republican primary
ballots now some states are open states
where you can pull any ticket you want
but when you go to a a state you are
going to have to pull a democratic
ticket or a republican ticket there's
going to be two two ballots one
Republican one
Democrat I'm I'm telling you I know I
know you think I'm helping them because
I'm the outlier here I'm the one saying
the [__] that no one else is saying I
get it but I'm not I'm not saying it
just to [__] be
different I'm not saying it just to be
[__] different and I'm not going to
say the [__] that everyone wants me to
say just be the same I'm telling you
what the narrative is going to be I
don't just shill for
Biden I look at what the rightwing is
doing because they're our
opponent if you're gonna if you're going
to play in a professional sports right
if you're going to play professional
sports would you just absolutely refuse
to never watch tapes of the other team
playing and know what their quarterback
does know what their running back does
know how they play what defense they
play in What offense schemes they have
huh would you not do that that's what
I'm trying to do is show you what their
[__] narrative is and show you what
our narrative should be to combat their
narrative because they're damn good at
it and Democrats suck at it and there's
no better example of it than this 14th
Amendment
[__] and yes I I don't like to
be I don't like to be the outlier I
guess
maybe maybe I don't like to be the
outlier I don't know but I'm not going
to I'm not going to not say the [__]
that I that I need to say that needs to
be said
because I'm the
outlier just not going to and I'm going
to show you the [__] that no one else is
going to show you like this little
[__] [__] here with this Colorado GOP
terrorist excuse me chairman I don't
want to offend Chaz the snowflake but
let's listen here uh as he came into the
room back I read today that that Trump
will be on the ballot in Colorado yes
he'll be on the ballot because we
appealed the decision yesterday and that
and that forced Jenna Griswald to
begrudgingly print his name however the
votes may not count she won't count
those votes unless the Supreme Court
forces her to okay all right so let's
stop it there so let's go over
this this ridiculous back and forth that
we got to have because people just don't
want to [__] just battle at The
Ballot Box Battle At The Ballot Box okay
so you notice his narrative you notice
what he's saying you notice what he's
saying right he's saying we appealed we
won that appeal and she is forced to
print this um happy egg says um you
aren't an outlier we all agree we just
believe there's many roots to success
well that and and again I understand
that too like the the way to not let
Trump be president again is for him not
to be on ballots but the problem that I
have with it is that that's not that's
not a democratic way it's it's not it's
not a democratic way you're you're
actually as much as I hate that
[__] and I don't want that
[__] to be anywhere near my
[__] government or your [__]
government or our I don't want him to be
in charge of anything anymore in our
country and frankly the guy just sit in
a [__] prison cell for trying to
commit a coup and overthrow our [__]
government and overthrow our vote [__]
him [__] him now I don't know if he'll
ever serve an actual prison sentence I
have no idea that'll come we have that
decision at some
point but the point is is that this is
not a route to success I don't believe
it's not a route to success it's not
it's a deadend road and not only that we
waste all the energy going down this
Dead End Road and we give them the
narrative because he's telling you the
narrative right there in what I just
showed you he said he said
it if the supreme court allows her to
count these votes they're not going to
count the votes don't you see don't you
see
it don't you see
it listen there's a couple different
scenarios here in what he just said a
the Supreme Court decides to put Trump
back on the ballot now he's on the
ballot he can win the votes and they
have the narrative h ha haa na na boo
boo you can't do your little fascist
thing that's what they're going to say
that's what they're going to say that's
what they're going to say you can't keep
get to use the courts to get rid of
trump that's what they're going to say
that's a b is the Supreme Court rules in
favor of Colorado which I don't believe
they
will it's my personal opinion and that's
the opinion that I'll say into this
microphone because I'm not scared to
give you what I actually
think I'm not just going to say what's
popular on Twitter I'm going to give you
what I actually think and I'm not going
to let a bunch of people on Twitter or
the internet or social media convince me
of something that I have thought about
thoroughly and looking at it and through
the lens of narrative now B option b is
they rule in Colorado's
favor Colorado GOP has
guaranteed that the secretary of state
will print Donald Trump's name on that
ballot it does not matter what the
Supreme Court decides listen to me it
does does not matter what the Supreme
Court
decides his name will appear on the
Colorado ballot and people will vote for
him now if option b happens and the
Supreme Court says that the Secretary of
State in Colorado cannot count those
votes guess what the narrative is going
to be the same narrative that they
brought out of 2020 the lie but now it's
the
truth the big lie but now it's the truth
doesn't matter you but Tony the Supreme
Court and this and the law and the case
and the 14 section three and it says it
doesn't
matter it doesn't matter with narrative
it doesn't [__] matter that's why I
don't give you graphs I don't give you
polls I don't [__] fill you for books
of
encyclopedias I don't quote [__]
court cases
that's why I
don't because it has nothing not a
[__] thing not a goddamn thing to do
with narrative
nothing humans are funny creatures
they're really funny
creatures we have a whole lot of
cognitive dissidents built in it's
actually a survival technique if you
want to know the God's honest truth we
use cognitive dissonance to
survive a lot of people use cognitive
dissidence just to make it through the
[__]
day some people believe in have faith in
religion that might not be real and they
may not actually they may know that it's
not
real it's cognitive
dissonance it maybe one of the
advantages that I have I'm not bragging
or patting myself on the back but I
don't believe that there is a higher
power I don't believe that there's
anything beyond us I believe that's all
Hocus Pocus it's all [__] I don't
think there's anything else I'm truly an
atheist sometimes it hurts because I
don't get to use cognitive dissonance as
a survival
technique I don't get to pray I don't
beg for someone to change something that
that can't be
changed but it might be why I'm so good
at seeing this
stuff cuz if option b happens okay if
option b happens which oh all the
Liberals out there want that yeah get
him off ballot [__] him it's a primary
ballot it doesn't make a difference it
ain't going to make a [__] shine all the
difference
here and I'm going to show you why I'm
going to show you why it's not going to
make a difference he's still going to be
he's still going to get all the
delegates from Colorado they're going to
go to the Republican National Convention
and Donald Trump is going to win on the
first ballot and every [__] delegate
from Colorado is going to be Donald
Trump's every [__] one of them I
don't give a [__] if it's a or b option
that
happens it's authoritarianism he's the
dictator he's the cult
leader you're not dealing with normal
[__] we're not in normal
times
if option b
happens we're talking about narrative
here I'm not talking about the law I'm
not talking about oh what the Supreme
Court the secretary of state was she's
Force I'm talking about only the
narrative only what people are hearing
the memes that will be posted on
Facebook the [__] that will be said in
in offices at family
gatherings
the [__] that people whisper in each
other's ear chuckle while they're having
a beer in a
bar that's what I'm talking
about and the big lie the big [__]
lie in 2020 was that somehow Democrats
stole it they created ballots they kept
him off the ballot they they they
shredded Trump ballots they got rid of
those they threw them in the river they
got Chinese ballots and all that
[__] all those
lies are now going to be the truth
because Trump and option b where the
Supreme Court decides that he cannot
appear on the ballot it doesn't matter
he's going to be printed on the [__]
ballot and they're not going to count
him and you're going to hear it over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and over again
that's why I hope they ruin his favor
Trump I hope they I hope they let him on
the
ballot there's one thing that will make
us lose this
election it is
narrative I want my democracy to survive
past
2024 it is the reason why I have this
stance in the first place because I have
thought past the this simple fact that
Trump won't appear on a primary ballot I
have thought past that
point I used my thinky
space and to see what they'll say
because let me tell you they're going to
put him on the nominee no matter what
listen so so you're saying that he will
be on the ballot for the primaries I'm
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt but
he'll be on the primary for the or on
the ballot for the primaries but your
state may not count those votes how
would that work if your state chose to
not count the Trump votes would you go
with who came in second H how would that
work well worst case scenario if the
United States Supreme Court doesn't
overturn the ruling in Colorado um what
we're GNA do is we're gonna ask the
Secretary of State to not even send out
a primary ballots with you know that
type of rig system uh okay did you hear
that did you hear the narrative did you
hear it do you hear it forming do you
see it do you see what I see do you see
what I've been seeing the entire [__]
time do you see do you see do you see I
know most of you see and I and I I know
I know I know most of you probably agree
with
me on this issue I know you
do I know you do and and what I'm trying
to do is arm
you when you have people pushing back on
you to show them that the only thing
that Ma it doesn't [__] that 14 [__] the
section three rather it's clearcut which
it's not that's why they're asking the
question doesn't matter the court case
which
state
narrative is what drives
elections Jinx says they they've used
that narrative oh I got the wrong one
you've used that Nar they've used that
narrative for seven years now yeah they
have and it's been in a [__] lie the
entire
time the majority of the country doesn't
believe that
[__] guess what they'll believe now it
will be the truth he will be on the
ballot and they will not count the
votes I'm telling you I'm telling you I
know I know you don't think it's I know
you don't think I'm right
I know that I know you don't that you
don't want to believe
me it's cold hard
truth just cold hard truth
man and I want you to disagree with me
to some point Jinx so that you think it
through I want everyone to think this
through especially people who are really
concerned about the pro democracy
Coalition democracy surviving
2024 as we go into
it cuz this decision is going to be made
next
week and if it goes in Colorado's way
you're going to have state after state
after State doing
this and there's going to be a lot of
states where Trump's name is on the
ballot but they don't get to count them
and their narrative that they've been
spewing the lies they've been spewing
the last seven years or however
long it's G to be
true it's G to
hurt I
know you don't want that to get in the
way of what feels
good I don't give a [__] what feels good
I don't care what feels good in this
moment that is not what matters to
me
I want our democracy to survive past
this
election and I and I'm I'm not begging
but I will yell and scream and I will
defend my position of democracy until it
is
gone Garen goddamn T that [__] doubt me
on that you can doubt me on a lot of
things you might not want to doubt me on
that
but as soon as we hand them the
narrative that they've been saying the
last seven years and we laughed at them
we mocked them really you think you won
the election there was 61 federal court
cases half of them were [__] Trump
judges and they shot it down they killed
it
[__] and you're going to give them that
to be the truth that's what you want you
want their lies to become the truth
truth cuz it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter that the old ones were lies and
the new ones are truth it doesn't matter
doesn't matter and it doesn't matter why
those were lies and why these are the
truth because you're like yeah but the
law the Constitution they should respect
the law what the [__] are you kidding me
Republicans respect the law okay Jim
Jordan not [__] not not complying
with the sput neither Kevin McCarthy
Scott Perry trying to get out of giving
his [__] his sedici text messages uh
Donald Trump not coughing over documents
and obstructing justice moving around
Mar Lago including putting next to the
[__] give me a [__]
break you're relying on [__] that just
ain't real so I get it Jinx and I'm glad
you're here and I'm glad you're
commenting I the engagement is important
because this [__] 14th thing man I'm
telling you against all other things
this can absolutely kill us that's why
I've been speaking out against
it m Mad Max says we see Tony I know you
guys and mo most of you guys see this
stuff because you come here every you're
here every [__]
day you're every goddamn
day and I'm trying to show you and I
think it breaks through I think it
breaks
through and yeah am am I pissing a lot
of people off by saying this stuff sure
because they want him off the bout or
whatever cuz if feels good
but uh Jinx says it's not about feeling
good it's about the laws and the makeup
of the this that make yeah I get it
right right I I get what you're saying
but it's it's not it's not a
crime right we're not Prosecuting a
crime
here it's someone bringing a legal case
against them and using a part of the
Constitution to interpret what the
outcome that they want we're not talking
about criminal law here it's not what
we're talking
about cuz if it was criminal law we were
talking about he would be indicted on
Insurrection and he would be or
convicted of insurrection and yes
absolutely it says that in the 14th
Amendment Section 3 absolutely that's
clear cut and dry every secretary of
state would say well he's not on the
ballot and they would win those cases
Time After Time After Time After Time
time time time time time time again they
would win every [__] one of those
things and none of these [__]
would ever be able to use the narrative
because he was indicted or convicted of
insurrection and that's why they took
him off a
b but that's not what is the real that's
not
reality yes he did commit Insurrection I
get it I got man yeah well great uhuh
great
great now someone says you sound scared
no I I'm not scared I know what's going
to happen
I'm very confident in what's going to
happen that they're going to side with
Trump
here what I don't want to have
happen is to have the narrative slip
through our [__]
fingers that's what I don't want that's
why I'm trying to be the voice of reason
here in the narrative as opposed to
cheering on stuff that's going to kill
our
narrative because I know what theirs is
listen and they're going to IGN us and
then at which point I'm going to just
simply ignore the the primary results
and we'll we'll pivot into a pure caucus
system where all the candidates uh can
fairly compete and and uh try to get the
delegates that were afforded to us to
the National
Convention did you hear that he's going
to ignore not just the court ruing he's
going to ignore the
results so even if even if someone
resoundingly wins resoundingly let's say
Nikki
Haley Nikki
Haley gets 75% of the vote in Colorado
and it's a resounding
win he's going to ignore
it Anna says going to cheat yes they are
you can guarantee it why are we setting
up a system where they can
cheat let them nominate him what the
[__] are you scared of I'm not scared of
trump someone just said I was scared I'm
not scared of trump I'm not scared of
him I'm not scared of him being their
nominee frankly I wish them to make him
their nominee I think he's the easiest
[__] to
beat in a race against Joe Biden [__]
slam dunk our democracy is saved if it's
Trump vers Biden
don't get in the way do not take the
shovel out of their hands when they're
digging their political grave and that
is what we're
doing with this 14 [__] we are trying to
take the shovel out of the Republicans
hands as they're digging their political
grave [__] that [__] let's get them a
goddamn back
ho cuz we know they're going to try to
cheat like they're going to try no
matter what no matter what happens
they're going to try to cheat
listen can I ask just one more thing
Nick
Ryan go for it Sarah um thank you so the
Supreme Court is is quite conservative
wouldn't you expect that the court would
rule in Trump's favor given the makeup
of the court right now Jesus Christ so
well let me just answer that question by
kind of telling you a little bit about
what the Trump team and our team thought
uh going at the at the district level
when we this whole started at the
district court level we thought we were
going to lose all right so did you hear
what he said there he gave he said the
quiet part out loud us and team Trump
not us and all the republican nominees
teams nope us and team Trump this guy
this Dave guy this Colorado GOP
terrorist excuse me
chairman he's he's a trump boot licker
it is it is by Design an authoritarian
regime that you make sure the people
that are in charge of giving you the
power
are at your mercy they're totally loyal
and their [__] bootlickers that's the
whole point of authoritarianism if they
dissent at all you get rid of
them one way or the other most time they
use killing as a way to get rid of
people I want to bring up a comment here
on Facebook Tony Michaels toughen up you
taking orders from maggots what the [__]
I hope you're joking relax celebrate I'm
celebrating over the mate teers I am not
celebrating over losing narrative [__]
no I am not celebrating that I'm not
gonna stand around and go yay we won but
we're not gonna win
really it's really dumb I'm not going to
do that so I appreciate the comment
Xavier and I I appreciate you being here
and and commenting and and listening and
joining in on the antifa uh daily
meeting here but I'm not going to
celebrate what will ultimately lose us
[__] votes no no I'm not going to
celebrate that that's not going to
happen all right let's go back to this
here let's listen uh to the seditionist
here um or excuse me chairman we thought
judge Wallace would would kick him off
the ballot and say that he that he
engaged an Insurrection she did say that
he engaged in Insurrection but she kept
him on the ball so we were wrong on that
one we thought thought the Colorado
Supreme Court would would more or less
keep them on the ballot probably not
overturn the Insurrection part but they
wouldn't go that far and and kick them
off the ballot we were wrong on that one
so we're already 0 for two in all right
so this is really important and Xavier
put another comment here he says Tony
Michaels you the man glad we can
disagree more power to you yes
absolutely we should be able to disagree
and we should be able to disagree inside
of our own space um and really honestly
outside of our space um and I'm hoping
uh as time goes on here and as you're
shown that the narrative will slip from
us if this happens to be option b then
yes um you will say well [__] maybe Tony
was right so which I think is going to
be option A folks I actually have
optimism I think it's going to be option
A I don't I think this is all going to
be [__] in the water it's not going to
make a difference um come mid January
when these primaries start and Trump
starts winning boom boom boom boom boom
it's clear he's going to be the nominee
um his trial gets moved to sometime in
the summer the DC trial will be first
they will move they will move the uh
documents trial because of the Canon
will move the documents trial because of
the scheduling that Trump will have
conflicting they'll move that trial
they'll move the Manhattan trial um and
they'll move they they'll also move some
other court things that he's got going
on including Georgia they'll move all
that Ford and DC will be first I hope
it's first I hope it's the October
surprise all right let's keep going here
on the um on the on the on the
seditionist I I mean the chairman
predicting how the Court's going to
behave I can't tell you with 100%
certainty that the Supreme oh a point I
forgot to make so he said we're 0 for
two remember he said me and the Trump
team thought that we were going to lose
this one and lose that one folks that
means they were counting on
it
okay follow me here they were counting
on losing those battles they wanted to
lose Trump wants the Supreme
Court to [__] ruin Colorado's favor
now he does and the reason why he does
is because he's going to be on the
ballot he wants them to rule in their
favor because as you're going to see the
Colorado GOP seditionist terrorist I
mean chairman here is going to tell you
they're going to give him the nomination
and the delegates no matter what no
matter what happens they're going to
give him the delegates they've already
agreed that with Trump that's how it
works with a dictator and a cult leader
that's how [__] it works I don't know if
you know that that's how it works in a
fascist regime in an authoritarian
regime they do what the dictator wants
that's how it works that's why he was
[__] impeached twice and the Senate
didn't vote to convict it's the reason
why Time After Time After Time these
people who knew that the big lie was a
big lie they kept running around the
country it's the reason why Rudy juliani
is [__] broke it's the reason why all
these [__] January Sixers in goddamn
prison Time After Time After
Time
Trump wants to be on the ballot and
doesn't want the secretary of state
state to count them that's what he wants
listen to them court is gonna do the
right thing in this and I'm mainly
concerned because there are justices on
that Court like John Roberts who care
more about the reputation of the Court
as opposed to the letter of the law and
enforcing uh the law as it as it is
written so I don't know I I don't I this
is a crazy time we live in I never
thought it would get this far uh to
begin with so we're prepared for for all
scenarios could I ask him a question
Nick yeah or Ryan um sir yeah sir so you
said ask okay fine you said you would
pivot to a caucus system but if this
okay so uh Tara here I want to set this
up Tara here is going to ask because all
this decision is around the primary
ballots and the Colorado uh GOP
terrorist here excuse me chairman um is
saying that he's going to give the
nomination to Trump even if he's appears
on the ballot they can't count the
ballots they're going to give it to
Trump anyways because they're going to
do a caucus and they're going to rig it
up to where Trump wins that's what he's
saying and he's says it later too he
said and then saying so many words but
that's what the [__] he's saying but
Tara here is going to ask him about the
general election ballot make sure you're
distinguishing this because this is very
important she's trying to distinguish
the the primary bot from the general
election about listen the Supreme Court
and I don't think this will happen for a
minute by the way but if the Supreme
Court were to rule against you wouldn't
that mean regardless of whether he was
your nominee he would not be on the
general ballot for the the general
election
um they would certainly try to go that
route but I'll be damned if I'm going to
let unelected judges especially those
from an opposition party dictate to the
Republican party I'm saying the Supreme
Court said that he it is correct that
they should leave him off the ballot you
would do what what would you do we'd
pivot to a caucus system and we would
and what about the general election I'm
asking you what would you do
then we would work with the Republican
committee to Duke it
out okay so he's G to work all that oh
man all that legal jargon he's going to
work the legal strategy which Tara is on
to him here I don't know if you picked
that up but Tara is on to him here and
she's going to um absolutely twist him
in kns here I'm going to show it to you
um but
he they're going to Duke it out that's
his that's his legal strategy here folks
that just shows you that they know they
know they're going to win Okay let's
listen what does that
mean in the in the court in the court of
law I mean you're sort of asking you
know what we would do worst case
scenario and the answer is we're in
Uncharted Territory we're not entirely
sure but we're not going to just give up
because the Supreme Court gets it wrong
uh we're gonna keep plugging away and N
we're going to nominate who we think is
best to represent us on the national
ticket and if that's Donald Trump I'm
we're we're not gonna give up just
because the Supreme Court makes a bad
ruling we're gonna keep can I ask you a
question so he's going to ignore the
Supreme Court they're going to ignore
the Supreme Court and they're going to
try to what they're going to try to what
huh what are they going to do and she's
trying to get him to say what they're
going to do but he won't say it and the
reason why is he can't he can't really
say it he can't really say
it but listen to this exchange with this
other [__] eater and the [__] eater so
the Supreme Court I mean I'm trying to
be as unbiased as possible here it's
probably visible where I land on the
situation um I'm more of a conservative
he loves Biden absolutely not um the if
the Supreme Court is supposed to be the
highest ruling law of the land if we
can't trust their decisions when we pick
and choose which decisions we choose
from them to go by at that point don't
we end up in chaos okay so this is a
good point but I want to bring up
a comment from KMP she says he's a hack
which yeah he's an idiot but he's just
not any idiot this is the guy who is the
chairman of the GOP in Colorado he is
the one that controls the process of the
Republican primary he's the one that is
the head of that party and he is all in
for Trump he there's no way this guy is
ever going to let Trump not win Colorado
no [__] way in hell they're going to
do everything they can to give the dick
and King what he wants and he's going to
get the delegates from Colorado so he is
a hack he is an idiot he's a [__]
[__] eater but he's the [__] eater in
charge he's a [__] eater in charge this
is the problem that we have this is why
I keep telling you the Republican party
is dead and we do not need to stand in
the way when they're digging their
political grave let them dig the [__]
grave let them dig it just let them dig
it stop trying to take the shovel out of
their
hand I I think the if the court were to
not overturn the Colorado decision they
would they would be putting this country
into chaos and the Supreme Court hasn't
always gotten it right I mean I I you go
throughout the history of the Supreme
Court especi oh this is really delicious
and this th this clip other than um the
other [__] that this guy's saying that
they want to [__] just basically rig
up the the Republican primary and give
it to Trump and then try to rig up the
[__] election by putting him on the
general election ballot damn the courts
right damn rule of law because that's
really honestly what the [__] he's
saying but this part that he says here
about the Supreme Court listen listen if
you can pick up what if you smell what
he's stepping in here let see if you can
smell it especially with their decisions
on civil rights or even slavery uh what
what what what what they're their
rulings I think what he's saying is they
ruled against civil rights and against
slavery but howwi he how he frames it is
a little weird it just I don't know
maybe I maybe I was smelling something
else that he was stepping in but you
know who knows who knows let's see let's
see what he says here uh about the
general election ballot because this is
important back I mean they're not
they're not always right and so just
because they get it wrong in the sance
doesn't mean we just give up so we're
going to keep find finding a way to
nominate the people or the candidate we
think is best and that looks like it's
going to be Donald Trump well just
really quickly that if the Supreme Court
does not rule in Colorado's favor um I
would imagine that many many other
states would follow suit right to remove
Donald Trump from the ball saying if
they if they if they do um rule in
Colorado thank you if they do rule thank
you tra if they do rule in Colorado's
favor that many other states would
follow suit to remove him off their
ballots and at some point it would be
you know not all states will do it but
at some point it will be where he can't
meet the electoral votes right are are
you guys looking at the bigger picture
here okay again this guy because a lot
of people in the comments are like who
is this guy this is the leader he is the
chairman of the GOP the Republican party
in Colorado that is who this person is
they are in
charge of
it you're in charge of
it that's who this person is his name is
Dave Williams I think I don't know he's
a [__] idiot but there's an idiot in
charge it's like when Trump was
President right like ah he's a [__]
idiot
what
no way all right there's some breaking
news but uh I don't know if I'm going to
go to that or not what the
[__] what no
[Laughter]
[Music]
way oh my God is it real or is it AI we
got a case um but here I I want to get
back to this first let me let me finish
this up we got we got 30 minutes to go
here oh boy godamn people are not going
to like this when I [__] break this
story here all right let's let's
continue here this 14th Amendment [__]
listen to what he says though listen to
what he says at the end listen yeah the
bigger picture is that it's a
constitutional crisis and we won't have
free and fair elections and so if they
kick them off the ballot I think we're
in much deeper trouble uh as a country
you know I don't have all the answers
but what I can tell you is we go to we
got to viciously uh fight for our right
to vote for whoever we think is best
there it is Donald Trump is who we think
is best Donald Trump is who we think is
best and they're in the they're in the
bag for him folks and I'm telling you
I'm telling you this is not going to go
away for
this and this narrative that they're
going to spin
here is is going to catch to some
degree and cheering it on right now is
not going to is not going to
help so I hope that helps in the in the
whole thing um and I might get back to
it but I got to go to
this oh my god oh man all right so I
have interviewed this person several
times I've talked to this person in
private several times
um he may or may not like me I don't
know I don't know what am I supposed to
do um but this is a this is a um this is
an AI story um it's
also and this is true to
um small rat's heart let's get small rat
up here on the
screen you you there's a couple people
sent me this news but you you sent me
the
um um a link in the comments here and um
let's see let's see if I
can oh that's that's something else okay
but this is we got we got a
um now I'm gonna warn you because I know
a lot of you love mouch and I know a lot
of you love Michael Cohen um and this is
an AI story and this is why I have tried
to point out that AI is going to play a
big Ro
okay and why I'm saying that we're going
to do bonehead of the year next year
because you never know who's going to
appear okay um
and oh
boy here's the news uh ex Trump fixer
Michael Cohen admits he accidentally
used Google bard which is an AI platform
am I right rat is it a is it the Google
bard is a is an AI okay yeah all right
to put fake cases into the legal
filings oh my God oh my God listen
listen I know this feels like oh but
this is a loss but this is what I'm
talking about this is what I'm talking
about you cannot get too invested in one
[__] idea stop getting so
invested in one idea if you get invested
in one idea and it [__] flops you
might be [__] you might be [__]
okay now I I believe that these fake
cases if we read this article a bit it's
in filings that he filed um to I guess
um he was researching now let's just
read here here I'll bring it up I got
ads and [__] hang on all right this is
the top line of the article it says ex
Trump lawyer Michael Cohen used
artificial intelligence to perform legal
research that led to fake cases being
cited in his request to have his
probation cut short okay so this makes
sense all right so Michael Cohen is a a
served a federal prison sentence okay
now with a federal prison sentence let
me tell you how this how this works okay
so generally when you're sentenced you
have your your prison time and then you
have what they call your paper uh in the
federal system there is no parole they
don't have a parole type mechanism in
the federal system you serve your time
now there is a thing called good time so
if you don't get in trouble while you're
in prison and they don't take your good
time away from you then you get out
early okay that's your good time does
that make sense R you don't actually
have parole but you get you get like
good time if you're good yeah okay that
makes sense now uh as we know Michael
Cohen was released on an ankle monitor
to to serve a part of his sentence at
his house under house arrest which is
typical sometimes now his wasn't as
typical because there was covid stuff
and all this kind of nonsense now he is
on probation because he has what they
call paper or probation because there's
no parole so he has to serve that
probation now some uh federal inmates
who are who were ex-inmates serve that
entire probation period they they serve
their entire paper is the way that they
the way that you would say it okay so
you serve and maybe it's two years three
years I'm not really sure what Michael
Cohen's paper what his sentence was or
what his paper was um meaning his parole
or his probation period but a lot of
times you can petition the court and the
judge to reduce that so if you did you
didn't you got all your good time and
you've never had any kind of strikes
against you um then what what you can
actually do is you can file for the
court to get your probation shortened
which makes you uh leave the the actual
prison system at that point because once
you're released off your probation
you're no longer considered an inmate
because even if you're on probation if
you break your probation in a certain
way and you and you do that you can go
back to jail or prison you can go back
to prison if you break the conditions of
your paper so you want to get off your
probation or your paper as soon as you
possibly can um and that's what Michael
was trying to do here but in his effort
to try to do it uh Cohen and his
attorneys said in filings unsealed
Friday after the court threatened to
sanction Cohen's lawyer upon discovering
that the legal filings pointed at the
case did not
exist oh my
god um so um here's what the point that
I want to make on this okay here's the
point that I want to make is that and I
I've talked to Michael um I've had him
on the show um Michael brings a certain
commentary to Trump um that no one else
brings because he was part of the
Despicable piece of trash that Trump
really was and protecting the piece of
trash that Trump really was Michael was
that guy and he was right there okay he
was right there but you shouldn't invest
too much into how Michael is going to
take down Trump and how Michael um Cohen
is important to the National narrative
right Michael Cohen is not integral to
the National narrative one of the
reasons why is because Michael Cohen has
been out of the Trump Loop and the Trump
orbit since the first six months that
Trump was in office and the reason why
is because people found out that Michael
Cohen wrote a [__] check the Stormy
Daniels hush money
check that's it hush money so you
shouldn't invest too much like you you
should not come here every day and
worship the gospel of Tony that's why I
tell you
descent prove me wrong tell me I'm wrong
yes tell me I'm wrong please I welcome
that I welcome that I welcome
that that's the whole point that's the
point of democracy is not to rely on one
[__] that's
authoritarianism you shouldn't do that
stuff you shouldn't rely on One Source
on one Avenue on one [__] you
shouldn't you should not do that real or
is
it I'm trying to make Michael dance here
is it real Michael
or is it AI I I at its heart I think
Michael did a service to his country I
want to say that I want to give Michael
Cohen credit here um even though he does
not deserve credit um on pointing out
legal cases in his
filings oh my
god
oh and the reason why they're sanctioned
the attorney I'm sure of it without
reading the rest of the story is because
the attorney's responsibility before
filing this motion is that the [__]
cases that are in the motion are real
and not
AI all right the other thing that this
does
unfortunately is kind of diminish the
thing that Michael Cohen did because as
you remember when Michael Cohen's ass
was on the line Michael Cohen went
against Trump and he totally could have
Michael totally could have stayed in the
Trump Camp he totally could have I know
some people don't think he could have
but he could have he could have done
what a good boy does just like Mike
Flynn did just like Roger
Stone just like Paul manfor did and he
gave them pardons he could have been a
good boy and got a pardon you understand
that
right he could have got a pardon Trump
was the [__]
president he could have got a [__]
pardon but but Michael didn't play that
game Michael went and did his service to
his country and he went and testified in
front of Congress now I don't believe
that it's some sort of service that
Michael went and served a prison
sentence because he did those things he
did those things I think Michael kind of
skewed the story sometimes when he said
he was unfairly imprisoned which I mean
if if he did those things for Trump and
he thinks Trump should be in prisoned
for those things
and but he did a service to his country
when he went and testified in front of
Congress and he showed Congress the
truth about Trump and he did it long
before the big lie long before the first
impeachment long before the second one
and M Michael Cohen deserves credit for
that and he deserves credit here
for using artificial intelligence oh
Jesus Christ and really honestly now
this is on his [__] lawyer too what
lawyer wouldn't check these cases to
make sure they're real in this [__]
world of
AI so thanks for thanks for bringing up
everyone who sent the link and and
uh rat's cashing in on his story at the
very end of the year he's got like 15
minutes yeah AI story right there at the
[Music]
end oh I guess some people in the chat
are confused because they paid
money to pay for Michael's
attorneys the same attorneys who are now
uh getting threatened to be
sanctioned
folks this what I tell you all the time
this what I tell you all the
time this is why I don't [__] try to
get you to buy this or buy that or
here's NAD here's NAD here there's NAD
there I mean I got to make a living this
is what I do for a living me I if I
don't get paid to some extent or I don't
make money to some exent I don't keep
this microphone on and I can't do what I
do and I appreciate every single person
that keeps this microphone on no matter
how much it is whether it's zero doar
and you just come here and watch or it's
the $100 uh uh uh tier on patreon I
appreciate every s and anyone who buys
shots or buys merch um I get people just
sometimes they say Tony you inspired me
today and I want you to keep going
here's five bucks here's 10 bucks and
and and they have a big message with it
they do they a lot of people will send
me a message and I hear you I see you
and I see every one of you in the
chat that's why I try to stay authentic
that's why I try not to just do what
everyone else is
doing and try to be what everyone else
is trying to be on Twitter or on MSNBC
or CNN it's the reason why they follow
me in the
narrative is because I don't give a [__]
about popularity contest I don't give a
[__] I don't care how many [__] how
many how many [__] Twitter followers
I have that that number means [__] to me
I don't give a [__] about if I had a
million I wouldn't say anything about it
I've got like 35,000 and I don't I don't
say [__] about it because it doesn't
matter to
me we are I'm telling you because of
our way of forming narrative through the
real raw
truth this type of [__] is probably not
going to happen
here because I'm not I'm not claiming to
be some big big expert I'm just
you I'm just some dumb
[__] in in commie Falls Missouri
at the antifa corporate
headquarters with a with a webcam and a
mouse and a
keyboard that's all I am that's it I'm
just
you and I have a
talent I recognize that I can get in
front of this microphone for two hours
and I can talk about this
stuff every [__] day two
hours this is the show where the host
insults his audience while repeating
himself for 2
hours that's what this show's
about and that's just I'm telling
you anyone who's disappointed that they
gave Michael Cohen money for his legal
things I don't know that you should be
that disappointed
I don't know that you should
be but maybe you should
rethink some of the things that you
believe and why you believe
them I don't know I want you to
descent I want you to
disent I want you to question what you
hear that's it that's
all and get to the real raw truth truth
of it because frankly honestly not only
Michael Cohen here has lost a lot of
credibility with this but with this news
that this is true and depending on how
true it
is midus touch lost a little bit of
their
credibility and I'm friends with those
guys I like Ben I like Brett I like
Jordy I'm I'm I'm in good terms with all
the other creators over
there this
I don't know tell
me tell
me um someone ask will they put him back
in jail no they're not going to put him
back in jail no no no because it was
just they're wanting to sanction the
attorneys you see because it's the
attorney actual
responsibility Michael's Michael's not
the attorney on the case Michael is was
an attorney he was Donald Trump's
attorney and he talks about a lot of
legal stuff with other
attorneys on channels that talk about a
lot of legal
stuff with other
attorneys and this looks really
bad this this looks really bad at on its
face it looks really bad especially if
you gave money for these attorneys who
weren't looking over this to make sure
my Cohen wasn't using artificial
intelligence to do legal
research and to have fake cases cited on
his request to cut his probation short
but no this is not going to send him
back to jail this is not a violation of
his probation this is a violation from
his attorneys because it's his
attorney's
responsibility to make sure that the the
the file motions are
correct Michael Cohen is the is the
subject
not the not the lawyer that makes
sense Mountain out of mole Hills okay
all right yeah Mountain out of mole
Hills
right just telling you I'm just I'm
just you can say Mountain out of mole
hill is all you want you say Mountain
out of molehill is all you
want you say it and say it but
again but again uh Kim P says here Ben
and my minus stouch will have to make
hard decisions it's possible I don't
know I don't know what the I don't know
how many cases I don't know what the
parameters of it were I have no
idea I'm just telling you this headline
sucks for
Cohen I'm just gonna tell you just gonna
tell you of course they want to
discredit Michael no I I I I don't think
they I don't maybe maybe you're saying
that Republicans one want to discredit
Michael maybe that's what you're saying
that's not what happened
here the reporting is is that in in the
court filing this isn't this isn't like
heay this is a judge has said this now
you bet hey if you're going to respect
the Supreme Court you want the Colorado
Supreme Court BL you better respect
this in the filings unsealed
Friday that the court threatened to
sanction Cohen's lawyers upon
discovering his filings did not
exist that's not people going after
that's they made a mistake now I don't
think that this is a mistake that's
that's detrimental and will kill
anything that might as toucher Michael
Cohen may have done but it doesn't make
it look good that's all I'm
saying that's all I'm
saying Michael Cohen discredited himself
this time baware says
yeah so
um uh and Tony says I think this could
have happened to any of us and that that
actually Tony that is a great point and
that is the point that me and rat rat a
that the point that we've been trying to
make about the AI stuff the the the last
part of yeah that's what we're trying
that's what we're trying to say and
that's why like I was trying to use AI
like openly be like hey look I'm using
AI hey look over here look at this
stupid [__] because I didn't want you to
believe that I was using
AI I didn't want you to believe that I
wasn't using AI when I
was I didn't want I didn't want that I
didn't want that that's not what I
wanted I didn't want you to think that I
wasn't you using AI when I was I thought
it's
disingenuous Daniel Daniel Porter says
Tony wants mindus such a look B I don't
want them to look bad no I was
Affiliated I like those guys I like Ben
I like Brad I like Jordy I like I
my I have friends that are
contributors for minus Dutch they've
done a lot of work for democracy they've
done a lot of work for democracy I mean
I don't agree with every single thing
they do and how they do it but that
doesn't mean that I want them to look
bad I mean look if you expect me if you
expect me not to bring this up just to
ignore this thing because I'm telling
you I'm telling you this is the same
stupid [__] when you believe something
about like the 14th amendment that just
is going to [__] the
bed you can't hold on to narratives that
are going to [__] the
bed you don't want to [__] the bed with
your democracy you don't you
don't don't want to do
it that's why I want you to send against
me cuz I'm not perfect holy [__] I'm not
perfect at all I'll admit that I'm not
perfect I'll admit when I'm wrong you
know I will hell if Nikki Haley is the
candidate for the Republican party and
she's the nominee boy I'll eat crow I'll
eat crow right here on the show in front
of
you I'll eat crow if Nikki Haley is the
nominee of course and I'll admit that
I'm wrong and everyone else is right and
I was stupid and I didn't know what I
was talking about I clearly didn't see
what everyone else saw I'll say it we'll
go we'll do two days worth of it four
[__] hours worth of
it cuz I don't care if I'm wrong
actually honestly sometimes when I'm
wrong it's a good
thing maybe I'm wrong Maybe I'm
Wrong Maybe I'm Wrong Maybe I'm
Wrong uh some people are saying that
might as such I had to cut ties I don't
know it's going to be the talk on the
internet over the weekend because a lot
of people support minus touch a lot of
people support Michael Cohen like I said
I've had Michael on the show I've had
him on the show and a lot of people have
left the broadcast I've lost like about
a 100 people at the broadcast because
they're probably like what the [__] why
is Tony saying this well because it's a
story what do you want me to
do what do you want me to do I mean
Jesus Christ they got a they got a a
YouTube channel that puts Michael on
he's got a podcast that continues to go
they got two million followers he's got
a lot of
followers they sell him as the guy who
knows everything about Trump hasn't been
in Trump TR world for many many years I
mean the only relevancy they has left in
Trump World is the Civil Trial which is
coming to an end which I mean you know
these are all facts it's all real what
do you want from
me and I think Michael Cohen actually
could carve out of space that he could
make commentary about political issues
but he only talks about Trump
only
so um and again I'm grateful to Michael
I'm grateful to Michael for what he did
when he went to the Congressional
hearing I actually think he did more
service for his country than almost any
other person that's been in Trump World
when he did
that and I'm dead [__] serious about
that you know I wouldn't [__] say it
if it if I didn't think it I think that
Michael Cohen did a service that that
hardly any other person in Trump's orbit
who left their orbit did and he did a
service to to his country he didn't go
on some television interview he didn't
he didn't he didn't you know do
something like behind closed doors he
went in front of the [__] in front of
the world in Congress and was asked
those
questions and he had to be asked
questions from the Democrats and the
Republicans and he did
that he did
that so I I've always had great respect
for Michael for that and I I will never
ever disparage Michael Cohen for doing
what he did in his service um to to his
country in that someone says not
deliberate but a mistake well right but
I get it but how do you I I know what
you're saying that it's not deliberate
but it is a mistake right so again a lot
of people don't like when I speak out
they don't like it it hurts feelings
they get hurt um but you know
that's not what we do here I don't I
don't [__] not say something because
it need not be said and really honestly
um I I know rat I know rat's in the
laboratory laughing his ass off because
we've talked about this that this shit's
going to happen like this very thing
we've talked about this [__] is g to
happen AI is going to [__] up everything
even [__] that you don't want it to [__]
up it is going to [__] [__] up
up so be careful be
transparent be authentic if I had to
give advice if like someone who had a
show on YouTube right or wanted to start
a show on YouTube or wanted to increase
their how many days they they view on
YouTube right or they do their show on
YouTube because I've been doing this for
a long [__] time this is episode
which one is it episode
549 is this episode I've been doing this
for a while I have a few under my belt
but if I had advice to someone I would
say don't go with the wind don't open
your sales and just go with the
political and the wind that is
popular that does you no good I mean
you'll get views sure you'll get views
it' be
great I would say be authentic is what I
would say and I would say that your goal
shouldn't to be have a YouTube channel
or a twitch Channel or a Facebook page
your goal if you're in the pro-democracy
Coalition if you want to form part of
the narrative if you want to commentate
on the political and social issues that
are so important to the foundation of
our democracy if you want to do that
what I would tell you is be
authentic don't walk away from
yourself don't hold back the things you
don't want to
say make sure you lean in the [__] that
you should say [__] lean into it
hard even if it pisses people off even
if people leave they'll come back
because you'll be there if you do it
every day and you have
resilience and you have
resolve
tenacity it's been a great year and I
have enjoyed every single minute
spending this year with you the audience
with the moderator the best moderators
in the world the greatest sidekick that
I have in the laboratory small rat here
yes yes my
friend we have the the the clip Master
skip we have our local librarian Mighty
librarian we have the meme General
Derek and we have the [__] them fam we
have Ty Ross too I don't want to forget
Ty Ty's our great PR expert she does a
lot of stuff that you don't see but
thank you
Ty we have The Mod Squad and we have the
[__] them fam and then we have the
sheeters that come and love to hate me I
love you too
[__] I love you too I love you
too you
haters and I'll be here next year that's
right next Wednesday we'll be back after
the new year year and we will start 2024
with a
bang and when we continue to tell the
truth the real raw
truth and we will do it every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern oh one person I'm sorry I forgot
there's a guy with the last name
Sanchez that we here at the [__] fam
own a lot to and I know I know he's
going through some changes in the shows
you know it's got some scheduling things
and we're going to he's going to work
through that he's already told me we're
we're going to get the bonehead of the
year next week so I gotta think uh the
guy with the last name Sanchez because I
I don't even know if I'd be here without
that guy I don't I don't know I don't
know it's hard to
tell there's a lot of people to
think and I I want to thank Ben Brett
and Jordy of mightest touch I don't know
that I'd be here if it wasn't for them I
I don't know that I'd be
here and I I there was no bad blood I I
left because I felt like I should I
needed to be more independent so that I
could tell you about a story about
Michael Cohen using
AI on his legal filings you think they'd
let me do that story if I was on their
Network [__] no hell no and that's the
problem is I don't want anyone telling
me what to say or what not to say I want
to be authentic be authentic and I want
you to be authentic to your fight in
democracy that's right I want you to be
authentic I want you desent because that
is the foundation of
democracy it is the foundation of what
our country and our society is built on
in the United States of
America it is the it
is the institution that drives our
Constitution that gives us the rights
and the
freedom that creates diversity Equity
equality in this country
progresses to a better life not just for
us but for the future of this
democracy and
this Democratic constitutional republic
will live long past
2024 just like it's lived and made it
through
2023 so I wish you a happy and safe new
year and as you're on your way out
please thank all those people The Mod
Squad all the people that help here with
the show give skip rat Mighty librarian
Tai the guy with the last name Sanchez
Derek give him all thank yous as you
leave and I want to know I want you to
know that you are valued as the [__]
fam here on the Tony Michaels podcast
from the antifa corporate headquarters
every Monday through Friday
ninja every single weekday two full
hours you get your antifa meeting live
from the antifa corporate headquarters
from commi Falls Missouri until next
year same time same place next Wednesday
I promise I'll be here so will you serf
up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the in
the meantime follow Tony on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
whoever this is with the last name s
Chase so what what so what's your
response whoever this is with the last
name
s nothing whoever this is with the last
name I'm not interested inid
about whoever this is with the left
name clear here okay what are you
talking about oh what that's that's a
personal attack oh oh I see the wi of
that is let be
clear these these immature people on
stage i' got to go whoever this is with
the last name people like and the more
differ whoever this is with the last
name whoever s whoever this is with the
last name
[Music]
Sanchez Sanchez I can't trust
that now I
get give it to me give it to me give it
to
me sucks gay w
[Music]
T
hey